- Let's talk about
the trans community.
We don't do that
enough on this show.
- I feel we do it more
than most shows probably.
- That's probably true.
A controversy erupted
last week when some clowns
who probably don't pay any
attention to Division II sports
unless there's some sort
of trans controversy
were upset because a
woman, CeCe Telfer,
won the 400 meter hurdles
in Division II last week,
and she had transitioned
into becoming a woman
the year before and so a
lot of people out there
are upset that, watch out,
they're taking over our sports.
- This is hilarious to
me because it's clearly
coming from a place of hate,
of I don't understand
the trans community
so I hate them, and I don't
want them in my sports.
No one in America
gives a flying fuck
about track and field.
(laughs)
In Europe, of course
it's a huge thing,
but in America no one cares.
- Especially this is DII.
- DII, exactly.
- It was DII, she's
at Franklin Pierce.
She had been competing
in men's track and field
before that and she
did win the 400 meters,
which is a great accomplishment.
Boo is by no means
a dominant athlete.
Did not make the
finals in other events,
did not do particularly well
overall the year before,
but did have this one event,
and suddenly people are
paying attention to it
like it's the biggest
thing in the world.
- Exactly, like
they're ruining it
for the other women competing,
the women who were cis
women, I guess you say.
Competing in this thing.
But she's not dominating.
She won one event.
She's in DII.
(Gregg laughs)
She comes in 4th
place all the time.
(laughs)
- It's not like it's
some cheat code.
Like she gets to take
steroids and no one else does.
It is insane that
people are mad,
and if you're mad about
this, it's truly coming
from a place of hate
inside your own heart.
If you have the courage
to become a part
of the trans community and
go through all of the hellish
things you have to
do to transition,
you should be allowed
to play sports.
It's not something
they're doing just
to dominate womens' DII events.
(Gregg and Erica laugh)
It's not like the
400 meter hurdles,
winning that is like a
free pass around the world.
That she decided to go
through this for that.
If you're a trans person, and
you go through these things,
compete in whatever
sport you want.
And again, she's not the best.
If she was DI, like Olympian
or going through this,
and I don't have a
problem with that either.
If you transition
and you're the best
at what you do, great.
- Right, and everything
that the woman Telfer did
is totally, NCAA,
it is complicated.
They've had to make
rules about all this,
but everything she did,
hormones, blah blah blah
blah blah, was exactly
what the rules say you
should do and there
was nothing going on.
It reminds me a little
bit of sometimes,
and I saw this last week too,
like a minor league
baseball team will have
Pride night, you know it's
Pride month right now.
- Did you see the comments
on the Dodgers' post
for last week was
Pride night, I guess.
- No, see that's, I wasn't even
- They flew the rainbow flag
and the trans Pride flag
at the same height
as the American flag,
since there's all the flags,
and all of the comments
were literally in LA,
they should not be flying as
high as the American flag,
like this is bullshit,
it was insane.
- People are so full of hate,
and when you talk about flags,
here's another one.
At the hockey game, in the
NHL finals the other night,
I believe, I don't know if
it was in Boston or Toronto,
I think it was in Toronto.
They have, it must
have been in Boston,
it was American troops.
They have a color guard.
They have the American flag.
They have a Canadian flag.
They have the Massachusetts
state flag maybe.
There's a Boston flag.
But then they also have a flag
for Enterprise Rent-A-Car.
I swear to God
they're flying a flag.
- Yeah, that was in St. Louis.
- Equally with all the
other flags there's
a flag for Enterprise
Rent-A-Car.
(Gregg laughs)
That's how much
the flag matters,
and if you're mad that
the gay rights flag
is flying as high as
the stars and stripes,
and you're not mad
about Enterprise
Rent-A-Car being there,
get the fuck out of my face.
They're flags.
It's not that big a deal.
If Betsy Ross could
just make it up
off the top of her
head, who cares?
- Some local conservative
activist actually in Boston,
this is a totally separate
story but it's related,
are planning a straight
Pride parade in Boston
- What?
- Because they're getting upset
with all the gay
Pride talk in June.
And so they're doing a
straight Pride parade.
You know what a straight
Pride parade is?
Every other parade.
- Actually, actually, no
parade is actually straight.
(Gregg laughs)
They're all pretty gay.
I don't care who you are.
You can be the most anti-gay
Irish alcoholic wastoid
in the world, if you're in
a parade, that's the gayest
thing you've ever done.
I welcome our queer and
trans brothers and sisters
during this month of Pride.
Fly that flag higher.
I think that the United
States flag should be
at half-mast out
of embarrassment
for the way some Americans
are treating gay Pride month,
and that's all I have
to say about that.
- Our next story is
related to the NBA finals
where Drake is making
his presence known
as he has really throughout
the NBA playoffs.
It's been kind of
a fun storyline
to see Drake on the sidelines
in Toronto and Milwaukee
and in various locales.
- [Anthony] It's been so long.
- He had to cover up
during the first two games
of the finals that he has
apparently made a tattoo
over the last couple
years of Steph Curry,
who plays for the Warriors
and Kevin Durant's numbers
and a little message
underneath them.
And now that his team,
the Raptors, are playing
the Warriors in the finals,
he's embarrassed about
that and is covering it up
with an armband.
- Yeah, I think you
gotta sit at home.
If you got tattoos
of the other team,
he's a Toronto fan, and
I get he's from the six,
he wants to be the hometown guy,
he's annoying as
hell on the sideline.
It's like watching Jeopardy
with someone when they
just keep on trying
to yell out the answer
even if they're wrong,
they're just with
complete confidence.
(Erica laughs)
Him strutting down the
sidelines talking to players,
giving the coach a back massage.
- [Erica] Talking trash.
- Like yeah, you can't
play basketball, Drake.
Go rap or something,
but don't be calling
Draymond Green trash.
It just makes him look like
the biggest dork of all time.
I love the NBA's
telling him to cool it.
But if you have those tattoos,
you should stay home.
If you have to cover
up your tattoos
to go to a game because
you're such a fanboy.
You have the numbers
of other players,
which is a weird
thing already even
if you just got Toronto players.
- That's what I'm saying.
You should not get it
in the first place.
- No, it's a bad tattoo.
- Put another man's, another
just random athlete's
numbers on your body, then
it's not even your team.
- Exactly, if it was your
team, okay, I get it.
- Where's the
respect, self-respect?
- If I got Ben
Roethlisberger's number seven,
(laughter)
and like a Roethlisberger
written above it,
it would make
perfect sense for me.
It would be totally
in character.
You'd never have to cover
that up out of shame.
- Garth Brooks would do that.
He loves Ben Roethlisberger.
- Garth Brooks
without his shirt on,
he's got the full, it's
like a full jersey.
It looks like he's
wearing a jersey
even when he's bare-chested.
(laughs)
It's Roethlisberger.
- [Erica] Jesus.
- He had to get it fixed
'cause they misspelled
Roethlisberger the first time.
(Erica laughs)
But it looks good on him.
- I find Drake kind of
interesting because he is
the dominant, it's taken
me a while to realize this,
but he's the dominant
musical force in the world.
He has the crown.
I would say if you look
at the aughts in general
Drake is probably number one.
Not to me.
- Bigger than Beyoncé,
bigger than Rihanna?
- Talk about album sales, who
people actually listen to,
he blows Beyoncé and
Rihanna out of the water.
The only one that
would be even close,
over the last decade,
would be Taylor Swift.
That's definitely a different
- Taylor Swift kills him.
- Would kill him, but she
doesn't have the cred.
- That just makes him The
Big Bang Theory of hip hop.
Just because you're popular
doesn't mean you're good.
- [Erica] Some of
his stuff's good.
- He is good though,
he is good though,
but that's what I kinda mean
is like someone like that,
usually you're trying to
be cool and sort of his MO
is not cool.
He is not that
interested in being cool.
- I think he's very interested,
he just can't do it.
- Like, his relationship
with Rihanna,
he's very like,
I don't know if he's okay,
but whatever he's doing,
he doesn't come off as a
cool guy or the coolest guy
in the room, and yet
he's the most popular.
- He's corny, and
people like corny,
but I think the best part
of Drake during the playoffs
was when they were playing
the Milwaukee Bucks,
and the owner of the
Bucks, his daughter,
who's a beautiful young girl,
wore a Pusha T
t-shirt to a game.
- It was a good move.
- I was like, awesome.
That's the way you get
back at Drake is just
bring up Pusha T
whenever you can.
If you have tattoos
of the other team
that you're against, just
don't go to the game.
Stay at home.
- Unless it's a super
super, the Drake curse,
whatever team he supports loses,
and he wears all the
different jerseys,
and he did that for the
Bucks and all kind of stuff,
and then they
lose, and whatever.
Maybe this is the long-game
to have the Raptors win.
- [Gregg] That's confusing.
- And Drake's dumb enough to
get it tattooed on his body.
- He's corny.
- Does your three year plan
for the Jeselnik and Rosenthal
Vanity Project
- [All whispering] JRVP
- Junior Vice President
- Include any tattoos?
- Yeah, of course.
- 'Cause I feel like I'm
- I'm ready.
- Emika and I are itching.
It might not have to do
with this podcast or not,
but I'm ready to go spend
some money and get a tattoo
with my wife this summer
before the feeling leaves me.
- If you and Emika got tattoos,
and you would let me be
a third and get matching
tattoos with you guys,
I would pay for it.
I would set it all up,
and it would be
Draymond Green's number.
(laughs)
(rock music)
(beeps)